we're delivering these experiences that
have so much technology and technical
things that go into it but the guests
will never notice that they're just
going to have this amazing experience
with aquamels we bring the wonderful
world of Mickey Mouse and all of his
Pals we Infuse our water slide with that
story and why don't we just go one step
further than we've ever gone on any of
our previous ships let's bring this
story to life using Motion Pictures
within the attraction we have these
amazing watertight screens through this
immersive world of film in the conveyor
that's where you see the nine screens
experience of the show with Nikki and
Minnie and then the rest of the slide is
truly a water slide
[Applause]
the audio design with aqua Mouse we had
to prove to ourselves at audio music
could work in a tube and it works
amazingly the tube diameter of the
conveyors like seven foot diameter it's
the biggest thing we've ever put on the
ship so it's just amazing you're
standing there on a top deck and it just
feels part of the overall design
there are hundreds of screens on board
when you think about just how much
content it takes to make sure that those
screens are always presenting something
that's related to the brand of that
phase it's a huge dance it's a
choreography that has to happen behind
the scenes
the worlds of Marvel the quantum Corps
became one of our centerpieces literally
for our story and for our tables they
play into our storyline for the whole
dining Adventure that these are fresh
Avengers Tech that's been right at our
tables for us to interact with every
family has one that they can interact
with and play along with Ant-Man and
wasp through the whole dining Adventure
we've never done big Hollywood style
production especially for a restaurant
experience so this is unlike anything
else that we have at Sea really on those
100 screens that we have around the
restaurant someone on the team suggested
why not Ant-Man and the wasp and the
idea of technology gone wrong bringing
in Quantum Tech because shrinking and
growing stuff is really fun and that
just sets the seedling to bring that
story to life
you're going to be on the ship and
you're going to be enjoying a cocktail
or two looking at a beautiful view into
this world that you love to imagine in
and at the same time you feel like
you're actually flying because why we
got the motion of the ship happening
while it's not an active motion ride on
a mechanism we're getting that motion
for free from the ocean so I think it's
brilliant it's going to allow users to
experience the Star Wars Universe in a
way that they haven't yet been able to
the view out the window is about 20 feet
wide our final content was 6 in its
resolution so there are a lot of pixels
through that view
when you're on the ship you can unlock
an even deeper level of Storytelling
beyond what you see the guests can use
that true immersive experience to
trigger things on the ship technology
gives us new Tools in our storytelling
toolbox I think what we're seeing now is
interactivity as the new tool that's
coming into the toolbox so now I'm not
just passively watching a story I'm
[Music]
and the words of our founder it's a fun
thing when you do the impossible
foreign
[Music]